I'll tell you what I always forget about
on it besides the fact they have alpha
brain they got new mood they got
everything for your digestive health
they got a Kido collection they got
things for support and vitality like
krill oil joint oil active B complex
they've got essential nutrients earth
grown nutrients all kinds of stuff
vitamin d3 spray which is a lot of
people are deficient in that I use
shroom tech support I swear by if I'm
working out nothing gives me better
energy it's crazy
it actually works creatine they got the
best creatine on the market and by the
way creatine is the one thing that all
nutritionists seem to agree is actually
good for you they've got shroom tech
immune stuff for your music this is all
stuff that the owners the founders of
the company use themselves but what I
really like and I always forget is they
got Fitness they got fitness classes you
can you can watch stuff online and get a
serious hardcore half-hour workout it's
unbelievable man so on accom slash
fighter for 10% off it is the best go-to
company for any kind of supplements you
want I swear by it I use it so does
Brendan so does Joe Rogan everybody you
know so I was had my text this honored
the real deal I'm thinking about getting
himself and I know I use it and so does
everybody who owns the company we don't
go to other companies for our
supplements so yes the answer is they're
outstanding no no no no no I hear a
[ __ ] monster come okay I never seen
you yeah that's not true we could talk
about it though I just said oh my I've
never seen you do comedy and you just
said that's not true I opened a few
years ago Gotham and you uh you went on
stage afterwards you're like [ __ ] that
guy's really funny
oh really a month and then you said and
then he go but I'm funnier and I got a
huge laugh haha and made me laugh yeah
that's yeah well if I told you that I
meant it cuz usually I'll avoid somebody
if I know you're really nice well I hope
so yeah I always get a kick out of
people saying you were really nice
because Chris Rock one time I said I
said something I think came before what
I said I followed you last night because
we had sort of said I think it was a
nice to you
and I was like I think so [ __ ] wouldn't
you be nice I mean yeah you know I mean
you and now you were a dick okay yeah
usually people on a day it's it's like
you gotta gotta go out of your way I
think so yeah yeah what are you doing do
you special I did yeah I still produced
it I shot it in New York City at the UH
at the village underground which is like
around the corner from the Comedy Cellar
yeah and shopped it around no one no one
is interested so what a surprise
[ __ ] comedy so I was like you know
what I'm making it I just made it myself
and and I was ready to put it on YouTube
myself but let's because you you write
us you write an hour after why you get
so [ __ ] sick of it so she said get
rid of it so you can start that's why I
said amazing I'm like I don't care that
Netflix is one I got to get this [ __ ]
thing out exactly and I kind of was like
yeah these have a lot of me to jokes in
it has a lot of good I felt time ago so
yeah so I was like I'm putting that one
way or another and then I ended up kind
of struggling to deal with Comedy
Central's digital channel because they
have so many views but they put my last
hour special I did my last hour special
at Comedy Central on TV and no one
watches TV watches TV so then I'm I knew
that though going in so I said you got
to put the whole special on on your
website and they said okay but they put
an ad every three [ __ ] minutes
what so who's watching what yeah so this
is that was my one rule so dumb about it
I don't know how many central seems like
it's becoming more and more irrelevant
yeah well watch my special uncommon I
got this I got this
yeah what's your new one about uh just a
lot of short jokes and I tell one story
at the end which is about a vigilante
who saved me in Cleveland really yeah a
whole era teas oh they're great club
yeah what happened basically a
Valentine's Day LeBron had just left the
Cavs Oh Cleveland was [ __ ] angry they
were and they dessert they put
everything on LeBron that city so yeah
but by the way if I'm LeBron I'm getting
the [ __ ] out I love Cleveland I like the
people but I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
Miami even clearly yes I do you think
even Cleveland nurse even clipping the
guy goes you like Cleveland I go yeah
and he goes [ __ ] nobody [ __ ]
likes Cleveland I walked away
for me now where do I go they go well
there's a market if you just you could
go over the like 10 minute ride this
market yeah so market and that was it
yeah market or do you want to [ __ ] Cuban
models for an entire basketball season
you go Miami are you going to [ __ ]
Miami so uh yeah basically I met a girl
after the show and and she was there
with a guy but they weren't dating and
we kind of hit it off and he was buying
me drinks to keep an eye on hey so I was
like alright whatever
I'll take the free alcohol and then he
left for a second I just asked you do
you want to leave and we left and we
started making out and like on the
street then we end up in a bar we're
doing shots good night yeah night for a
comic it's good night and then I was a
feature too so it was even better even
better
I was headlining like an off night you
know all on your funny [ __ ]
alright Keep Calm so that looking kid
thank you
sleepy you look a little bit like a
sleepy you look like a thinner we [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] was the quarterback for the
Falcons oh no I never get him I would
get Flacco for the race oh good good
Flacco
people would say Michael Michael Phelps
but not the bottom [ __ ] I know
not the body he's not a good looking guy
he's good I know that he comes now
you're a good looking guy thank you
there is there's Flacco right there they
are
that's exactly why men got good hair
though look at that hey you have your
ears all right it's very Italian and
curly or as a Jewish I'm a Jew yeah joe
says that you like a Jew who looks a
little bit Italian but then you look at
your hair and you're like well I mean
Flacco yeah Flacco that's the that's the
Italian version if Flacco was a Jew EBU
and that's the Italian Cohen a Jew
Italian is almost a compliment because
it just means that we're not neurotic
well the Jews always the Jews would
always play Italians in the mobster
movies back to ya so James Caan played
Italians James Caan who's the Jew who
played the Mexican and the good the bad
and the ugly you know
oh yeah Wow yeah [ __ ] Eli Wallach good
call on Eli Wallach that's right live to
like 99 yes he did yes he [ __ ] did
you yes I did he went to my acting
school dance he was a great actor and he
said to me he goes do everything do it
all I don't give a [ __ ] if it's on you
know the and he was so good he goes I
don't care if it's on a cruise ship
I did everything and that's what I did
that was my motto I mean I never forgot
that I never said no to a goddamn thing
I did I did it oh that's so smart he was
he was phenomenal
he's a great great in that movie too
look at him back in the day you get they
weren't wearing sunscreen they were all
sweaty they they were sweaty for [ __ ]
real
so we tiptoe you're just like you just
like just tan a lot I'm playing to
Mexican that's it that's exactly right
just tan yeah so anyway I met that girl
in Cleveland it turns in like a whole
thing well I'm about to take her back to
the hotel and then the dude who we ditch
found us on the street and he was a
scary dude and he was like missing a
couple teeth I was like he's gonna
[ __ ] I can't fight dude I just you
know all you LA comics can fight all
this New York comics are drunks and
we're [ __ ] you know what I mean like
all you LA comics are black belts and
[ __ ] it's hilarious like yeah you're all
like I know you're a badass I mean I'm
not a badass but I'll fight and you I
mean in that situation I'm probably
gonna be I'll be hopefully better than
oh I don't know I just I know I don't
know I do fight this guy might have a
knife I don't want to get stabbed or
something so I was just like he's got in
my face was like you wanna do you want
to go back I I asked her like what do
you want to do and he just kind of was
like do you wanna do you want to fight
over and I was like no well you know
yeah but did not situation I'd be like
no I was in I was in Dallas that all I
was doing was talking to a girl who was
talking to me she was talking to me and
I was alone I wasn't doing anything and
she started talking to me and the boy
she was with the guy she was with
took her be ride her hand and smashed it
on the ground I didn't miss a [ __ ]
beat I literally turned I just it went
and I just turn and walk the [ __ ] away
I just turn and walk away I disappeared
in the crowd I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
[ __ ] fight over any girl
no I mean that I that I just met her
who's talking to me now that's a line
that says missing - he was missing teeth
nice I've never [ __ ] someone have been
like that was better than teeth yeah
those allies you know it's exactly right
it's just not yeah I got I had a thing
in Vermont this is another story from
the special but it's just you made me
think of because there's a plank the the
beer glass smash and a guy smashed a
beer glass over my head in Vermont last
year
don't seem like a bad you seemed very
unassuming nice I am I did nothing
what happened was out wasn't even at the
show I was two blocks away having a beer
with a friend of mine
Carmen lagana a comic who was opening
for me that show and when the were in
the bar and this guy just walks up to me
and he just kind of started [ __ ] and I
was just kind of like okay I was
ignoring him and something was off about
him
I could talent he and he just do two of
the comics there and he said he said you
go to he's a University of Vermont
Vermont I said no and he goes do you
have a master's degree you know I said
you're getting colder it's what I said
to him and he said I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of all of you and I just like
kind of turned away I was like he's not
gonna actually hit us I just kinda like
he's bluffing I turned away he took a
pint glass and just smash it over my
head and I turned around like it kind of
in shock I was like what do I do
you know so there's two other guys here
who will fight I know they stood up with
for me I'm always getting ready for that
moment and there's no way I would have
turned around I would have gotten I
would have gotten position that didn't
is why I boxed and do jujitsu at 53
because I still feel like I gotta be
ready
you're 53 yeah you should I know it's
ridiculous you look you look not 53 like
he right now I'm not in New York 53 if
you lived in Cleveland right now you
look like [ __ ] oh yeah it's LA I'd be
hunched over my back but I also work out
like I'm a man I work out I still train
that's all you look amazing
4:53 holy [ __ ] thank you sir that's
insane not bad not bad
I thank you well the guy anyway I found
out he he's you know he's a therapist
the guy who smashed a bottle of the
Penguins in my head he's a therapist he
his wife had just left him I could I was
talking to the victims at I hate that
[ __ ] word to the victims I'm a victim
but uh the victims advocate in Vermont
and she called me and he went for the
cops gone when the cops got him so that
he was hoping the cops would shoot die
he was trying to die but so now it's
like a felony in it and they were like
do you want to come out here I'm not
gonna come out there [ __ ] the deal with
this guy I think I was having a moment
he was he was having a moment of madness
I'm not gonna there's not a shot
I get on two planes to go you know
testify no first time I feel like a
[ __ ] second of all just not turn my
back my bad that's how I shine it
through my bag no I I am I
that's literally I'm always ready for
that I mean I I yeah I could that's
amazing that I get angry though that's
what it is a guy in Edmonton punched me
like this and smacked my face but he was
doing it like he was alpha in me who he
was big and he was with his group and I
could tell you the Alpha and he was a
Matt Bob and one like that and I had
been working on on this Grieco move this
gray where you reach up daniel cormier I
did it to to Frank Mir and I wanted to
know how to do it my friends a wrestler
so I read I got on the hooks I grabbed
him like this and I I i did this what's
called a knee pick I don't even know how
to well I would just was I practiced it
because I'm that much of a [ __ ] idiot
and I went I ain't I pulled him down and
I and I let go as he felt I grabbed his
ear and I pulled his ear really hard Wow
all right and he fell into the waitress
and he got with trees over and then he
said um and he just was so in shock and
then I slapped him
like I got grabbed him and I slapped him
but I did it not in a way where it
looked like I was fighting him I did it
in a way where it looked like I was um
like it looked like I was doing it back
to him and I was just more I was
aggressive and I think I told I said
something like I said I think I said
saying really weird like I'm a chimp
because I felt like we took down a big
dude well wasn't yeah he didn't expect
you know he was I I you know but it was
if you had seen it you wouldn't have
known what I was quite doing he just
didn't know either but I slapped him I
went back back and I was ready to
[ __ ] yeah I was so mad but I was
smiling and I think I went I got the
champ bro careful and then I walked away
and he sent me drinks all night Oh
waitress I go um
I can't drink I can't do this but so
fill it with water or ice tea because he
was sending me like he sent me like a
brown drink and I think it was like
Jameson's or some [ __ ] Mo's and the
vodka or tequila whatever the [ __ ] it
was
but he kept sending me and I kept going
all right water anyway it was I got that
story kind of Alfred you and you Alfred
him bag him and he took you God just got
angry I've been working on this
particular move but you bullied a bully
you bullied a bully and then he and then
he turn nice that I [ __ ] hate that
about people
yeah but bullies make me he was just
being a yeah he was being the alpha guy
and he was a big good-looking guy so I
already hated him for being bigger than
me and uh it's all insecurity for me
I just can't I got pulling around 8th
grade right I should I should have
smashed a pint glass over the guy's head
back and maybe he would have bought me
now my trauma like it is great I was
bullied really really early for a whole
year and so I we still live in compounds
in Saudi Arabia and there was a kid who
lived on my compound so there's no
escape
he lived in Saudi Arabia and the dollar
the Wow 14 India Pakistan Greece Saudi
Arabia Lebanon and he used to bully me
and I I was a coward I was afraid of him
and I did everything I could to avoid it
but I couldn't
so the humiliation of that when I when
you're a small young boy when I was the
firt and I was doing judo and stuff but
the first thing I did when I went to
boarding school was I became a wrestler
because I want I thought I'm gonna get
bit really big and muscular that never
happened but but I became a good
wrestler because I was for a high school
guy but I'm so insecure and I never
wanted to feel that way so the football
players never [ __ ] with me because I
was a wrestler and they were football
players so I never got [ __ ] with which
is a big deal for me it really matters
yeah you know and and but of course then
from there you go on to doing I did of
all the other stuff because I just
wanted to keep building an arsenal but
that's all because of the trauma I went
through in eighth grade that's all it's
not it's all it's probably all comes
from an unhealthy place you know you
know I still haven't lost it like I
could I would hate if somebody did that
I I know what Brendan's been with me
Brendan's been with me where it Brendan
Brendan Schaub who can [ __ ] pull my
spine off my head yeah and we were at we
were at a place in the valley and the
guy was we were talking to these did we
words is very innocently talk and these
girls recognized me and they were
talking and stuff and the dude the guy
comes up and starts like like we're
hitting on the girl and I thought to
myself he doesn't know he what if that's
my girl that's didn't hear dissing me
yeah I don't wanna go no one friend I'll
be embarrassed by him say this but like
he was like what are you doing what are
you [ __ ] doing and I you know I just
yeah it's more it's more it's more I've
weird and I slit his throat I killed him
I'm gonna delete this I know dude no I
won't I'm proud of it I I I'm a murderer
so that's the bottom line
yeah when he deserved it I'm sorry yeah
yeah and then and then I had to kill his
friends because they were witnesses I
didn't have to kill me cuz you and this
is the old list for me dammit
let's finish the pocket if I just took a
knife out right now my dad yeah if I
keep talking it's gonna sound like I'm
acting like a tough guy and talking
about fights and then I'm gonna get
roasted I'm gonna be very clear I'm a
[ __ ] hear my stories all my fights
no no so am i I'm not if you have any
doubt about my [ __ ] Ness watch please
watch Brendan Schaub and Bryan Callen
fighting on YouTube and you'll get a
sense of what my skills he's a
professional I mean he's you know he's
so [ __ ] is so strong but I'm I'm
determined and I think I can get I think
I can get position on him and I might
come in on in Crocs and he said he'd put
hands on me I remember I well you always
think you're like more manly I think
some people like things like well he's a
deep voice that would be cool to like
kick his ass and I'm like it but I'm not
straw devote the physique doesn't match
the voice but you look like an ass you
look at lenok you could be good at
asking that man's good at basketball I
can like hit bang shots pretty pretty
cat I'm like I'm a good like mid-range
shooter
I can hit passion I'm good I look good
like I promise I modeled my game after
like 90s players but I'm weak so like I
grew up on like the 90s Nick so I'm like
yeah I'm like oak but I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can't you know so I can hit I
can hit like jump shots pretty
consistently but I can't dribble I'm
slow and I'm weak I said I just came
from the set and I had to play
basketball all day I'm not a basketball
player yeah I had to look like one so my
co-star James Lou Ruth who's a great
actor and he plays ball and he was
having to teach me so I would just have
to mimic but I'm [ __ ] sore I'm gonna
be sore tomorrow it hurts the jumping
I got no vertical I'm [ __ ] I respect
bad school players so much men I I
respect like anyone who's a pro athlete
I remember I used to have like a nice of
a sports show on the Knicks Network and
I
have I remember this offensive lineman
he's a Pro Bowler Justin puon he plays
for the Cardinals now I think and I said
hey wouldn't be funny for a gag like I
tried to like your alignment so I tried
to like get through you to like sack my
you know my head writer and he's like
yeah let's try it
he just [ __ ] with two fingers throws
me oh yeah I was the most insane kind of
strength that's the biggest strongest
man in the world yeah let me see him and
fast and smart by the way you can't be
dumb and he was a great he's a great
dude too I'm sure
such a nice guy yeah but but you know
it's like I said the Goldberg you know
you know Goldberg the the wrestler oh
hell as a Jew you think I don't know
Goldberg
he's a [ __ ] pride yeah he played for I
think for seven years or whatever yeah
and he's so athletic he's a red and he
was he was like hitting this stunt man
he was running through the line of
hittin the stuntman at my age and dude
and he can fight too and like he
practices and I looked at him and I said
look at the size difference oh my god
what a [ __ ] I am and I said to him I
said um like I said the idea of fighting
you would because I realized what an
athlete he was I guess the idea of
fighting with that would not work well
he looked at me and he's such a nice guy
and he goes no no no you know like I
would kill get him oh my god me up and
throw me on my [ __ ] head that's
that's like the Brendan said you know
that's a bear dude you got a bad rap in
the WCW for a while because stone cold
was the big name in the WWF and he was
just another ball Jack guy who were all
black alright so as I was like oh this
is like another except he was he was
just a totally different type of fighter
he was like dude he's the real deal man
he's a man when you play pro football
for that long he played it I came out
replayed oh my mare yeah you don't want
to [ __ ] him out with that guy no no I
would not [ __ ] with mouth cold nose
guard no thanks it's okay he does his
own stunts he didn't trust what do you
think about like when Tom Cruise is
always like I do all my own stunts and
you're like dude take a [ __ ] break
like well I know a couple things about
him one is I've done I've spent a little
time with him yeah shaking his body and
believe me like like he did this
and reading and I am that's how I am
he's walking in front of me and he's
thick he's [ __ ] thick on cruises oh
dude he's five eight five nine but he's
he's wide like his shoulders he's got
traps and ditches he's never stopped
working out
he's got wide hips and thick legs there
is yeah damn I like look at that oh he
what did that photo Sean oh yeah what is
this I don't like what that is
that's not real no that's not real but
he's he's a [ __ ] wide man and he's
never stopped working out fire hydrant
man he was a wrestler too by the way was
he yeah Disney from like Syracuse New
York or something I don't know he didn't
know it damn he's shredded he's never
stopped wearing that in between takes
Artie Lange told me that he would jump
rope he's jumpy he's always jumping but
is he happy well he's never made a
relationship work yeah I don't know I
feel bad because I really think he's
from what I know about him which is very
limited but people I do know who worked
with him for a long time he's the nicest
man in the world
yeah that's the [ __ ] lady I love Tom
I just think maybe he's either
I don't know as he gazed he not is he
not is he asexual he's he lives he's
probably gay and he's probably it's
probably you know I mean no one reacts
the way he jumped in the couch with
Oprah when he found Katie Holmes that's
like I know what's crazy is he's a good
actor so that wasn't even good acting
that was weird
that was like a bad performance but he
is probably gay and probably trapped in
the Church of Scientology it's sad I
think that but he's a great actor man I
love I love him a Magnolia I love when
he does kind of like a serious turn I
love him and he's all those awesome I
love him in pretty much every movies and
I do time for lunch do I'm a huge fan of
his I really am I think he's I think
he's such a look at look at the [ __ ]
body on that [ __ ]
you know good luck good luck being as
excellent as he is for whatever reason
though I think he sold all his property
and moved down a Clearwater Florida
really yeah and he lives on the on the
or agree lives he bought up the top two
floors of a building that Scientology
the cut the church owns and God that's
good that's how he lives man I wonder
what his relationship what's the name of
the guy who runs Scientology again David
what's his name the guy who wrote the
book right he must
must be so lonely but so my a friend of
mine spent six months with him on a
movie and yeah yeah well that guy's yeah
but they have like a weird thing I bet I
bet Tom Cruise much [ __ ] hate in my
bed John Travolta must hate him nobody
nobody hears from that guy he seems like
a scary dude man I don't know oh yeah
that's creepy
yeah no no not from where I read going
clear and if there's any to trample he
does not seem like a good guy not a good
person seems like a real [ __ ]
sociopath look at him yeah looks he's
like a Nazi vibe oh there was like I was
like a cleanliness and like like an
order to which he has that reminds me of
like a not well in the he's a short guy
and apparently he suffered from asthma
as a kid and was very muscular like
looked like Lou Ferrigno or something no
he was young everybody and he's he's a
big smoker I guess I don't know is he
yeah he looks like he'd also be like a
game show host - yeah man I don't know
he he doesn't he's not he's not painted
in a good life but he's also he just
just it's not around he just disappears
yeah the dudes in the shadows are the
scary ones yeah he's absolutely a shadow
Church Scientology has been exposed by
the Internet then the problem is that it
was really really exposed you know and
so there of their membership is way down
and they they're not able to do that
anymore
yeah so I don't know I don't know man
although every every religions got this
problem I guess but uh but yeah they
seem extra creepy the way they like
follow you and [ __ ] I'll say this about
Jews we don't recruit the way
Scientology does and you know no yeah
his dad his own dad went bad on them
though did he have it yeah on Roman so I
don't know man
the way they that what they did with Tom
Cruise and no because Nicole Kidman's
father was a psychologist right yeah I
think that's kind of that was a term
that they use it's like toxic people or
something no it's called a potential
trouble source right okay pts I I was in
an acting class with a lot of
Scientologists really yes and my acting
class is written up in the book going
clear so you know I mean I my teacher
Milton Katselas who then left the church
and then I couldn't assume we're all the
[ __ ] actors went yeah people from the
church left and I was like what's going
on here the whole thing was really weird
I can't be around it I mean you know
some of the stuff made sense some of the
stuff was about you know taking personal
responsibility for yourself and and I
gotta say I been to the Church of
Scientology because I did I did Kirstie
Alley's show fat actress so she hired
nothing but Scientologists and we shot
there we stayed there you know and and
then I did a benefit for 9/11 when they
went it might cheer up so Christy Allie
show they like tell us some of your
secrets too while you're at it and
you're like why would I didn't know you
yeah yeah well no she was awesome I love
Kurt is she cool I [ __ ] love her
she's great she's a great person and I
and I have to say that I had the every
Scientologist I met I like they were all
nice people I don't know I never had any
issue with him I mean I even made a joke
I was like I was at the church and I
said I was I'd asked me to do this
benefit you guys asked me to do this
benefit I told my friends they were like
be careful and I was like what are they
gonna do time into a chair and make me
take responsibility for myself they're
all like wow yeah I gotta take it easy
so I don't know so I went to my boy
Joseph as Eames wedding and I went to
black tux and I got fitted for a tuxedo
and I gotta be honest with you I was
looking damn good and in fact I think
the whole wedding did it and they all
looked great comes in a box it I
basically went to a black tux studio got
measured and then they sent it to me and
what happens is if it doesn't work you
can you can bring it back to the studio
and they'll redo it for you right there
studio the fitting room whatever it's
called show rooms yeah a show room it's
basically a really easy online ordering
process also that brings your suit or
tuxedo straight to you you just pick a
style at the black tux calm web site you
request a free home try on so you can
feel the fit and quality before you
commit and if online isn't your style
the black sucks has these showrooms
that's what I did but from there they'll
ship your order two weeks before your
wedding so you can check it one last
time and make sure you check it but you
know they when you when you get a suit
a tuxedo that is fitted to your body it
looks so much better like so much better
and I know this from experience so and I
had a very good experience with them so
try it if you want your wedding to be
remembered for the right reasons order
your suit of tuxedo at black tux calm
the black tux the black tux calm and
enjoy 10% off with code tea fat K that's
the black tux calm and tux to spell to
you x4 10% off your purchase put in the
code tea fat k well I am a customer of
hims the reason my hair is so plush and
beautiful as I get my finasteride from
them they send it to me i I basically
I'll tell you I'm just gonna tell you my
experience I was like let me check out
this for hims calm thing because I was
spending a fortune on my other my hair
pills by a by a pharmaceutical name and
so they sell the generic the same exact
thing in generic form at a fraction of
the cost so I was I going to try this
out and what I did was I basically took
a picture of my hair sent it to a real
doctor and he basically said alright
you're approved and you know a couple
short questions I filled out a
questionnaire and now I get my pills in
the mail I never have to think about it
and so it's it's pretty awesome now you
can do the same thing with erectile
dysfunction if you're not blessed with a
rock-hard dong like myself you might
need a little help and that there's no
shame in that man I think like something
like 35 percent of men under 40 suffer
from erectile dysfunction something now
the thing about for hims is this is all
science-based none of this is snake oil
no this is gas station counter
supplements this is all prescription
solutions backed by science it's the
same exact medicine you get if you went
to a doctor because there are doctors
that have to approve this thing they
connect you to real doctors online save
you hours you don't have to go into a
doctor's office so as a as a customer
for hims dot-com /fa TK that's for hims
dot-com /fa TK
it's it's a great company prescription
requires an online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate or eval only
if prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information dive into
20/20 hair first right now my listeners
can get started with their first month
free go to forehands dot-com /f ATK fat
K yeah so what are you doing in LA I'm
just trying to do some shows like this
to get people to watch my specialty oh
okay you know watch Sam are all special
but what are you do any acting uh
not really I was in joke over like you
were you were yeah I was the comic who
went on who was on stage before Arthur
oh my god yeah
did he say anything to you yeah I talked
to him I don't him for a bit yeah really
yeah he was really nice really yeah man
I spent five days with him and he never
even really in my direction really I
mean he was just in character I don't
blame him whatever he did he was great
he he he texts me all the time we're
cool no no but we talked for a little
bit yeah what Stan why did I did a
different joke every take on the Joker
so I did like funny I'm shooting it with
Chris red from SNL yeah you know and
he's the host so every every take I get
to do a new bit for extras and I would
just keep I wanted to get a real laugh
so I would tell new jokes to really hit
right and then after every take Chris
will go one more time for Sam Morrell
and he's like I [ __ ] hate you so much
you get to like show off and just do
material and I have to just say a
scripted line one more time so and then
he introduces but then I thought well
I'm gonna get cut out why would I be in
this and he's in it you know so no
matter what cuz he used to bring up the
Joker you know so she then at the end of
it Joaquin Phoenix talked to me a little
bit and was really cool when he was just
like hey man I was gonna talk to me cuz
hey man I like your jokes okay yeah it
was really cool I've heard he's very
sweet very so much you're such a nice
guy I don't know the vegan thing and the
speeches are a little bit yeah when he
said in the speech he's like we need to
like something about cows we're not
respecting calves like due to Hollywood
like just started respecting women like
three months ago
baby steps Hollywood yeah they I love
the country that this country really
doesn't listen to Hollywood to their
credit yeah like when actors talk most
most of Hollywood like I'm a fan but
shut the [ __ ] when actors talk you
realize that they're [ __ ] actors
that's and they're nothing without
writing you don't even whenever actors
talk I'm just like oh you can't play a
person you didn't only play another
person you can't play you it's a very
strange and peculiar skill set yeah I've
met some wonderful people in the
business who are actors yeah but yeah a
lot of that diversity a lot of them tend
to be because it's a very peculiar skill
set it requires it's requires a very
narrow kind of mmm
well it requires actually a very broad
understanding of human emotion human
behavior
yeah there's no I don't want to diss any
but like Al Pacino these people are
amazing but I don't think it's you could
become very very good and famous and
also stay very ignorant about a lot of
things that's part yeah whereas another
you can't do that really as a comic or a
writer you just you have to deal with
people you know when you're an actor and
you were sheltered well yeah because
when you're an actor and your life has
been on a set you are treated like a
king you aren't really spoken to you're
always on set and if you started when
you were young like a guy like Joaquin
and you haven't stopped working you do
not you do you just aren't exposed to
[ __ ] that we've been exposed and also
the bar is so high like you see someone
like Brad Pitt in a movie he's so good
in a movie he always plays a cool
character a badass and he see make a
cheesy joke at the Oscars when he gets
to the speech and you're like yeah
people would laugh at that your friends
laugh at that because your friends all
kiss your ass but when you tell that
joke in a room full of people there's no
[ __ ] faking it that's right and by
the way they know that I mean actors
know that when they're but if they know
has someone to punch you one line up I'm
gonna save me a better line say this and
I have a witness to this which is John
Leguizamo I'm with John Leguizamo and
Sean Penn comes up and starts talking
those I swear to God I didn't know it
was Sean Penn I thought it was an older
guy
yeah all due respect I love sharp edges
but it's Sean Penn I swear to god that's
how I felt he was having I don't know he
was very very thin yeah
and he's just older you know people do
it after he shot milk yeah whatever the
[ __ ] it was and I seem to have a limp he
was walking there said something when I
looked like he had a stiff back I love
the guy I'm not dissing him I'm a huge
fan but III this is so lame that I even
saying it but he said Brian Brian Brian
is a comic yeah I know I know yeah and I
was like that's cause like I hope I hope
he's telling the truth
maybe you know I'm too old to be
thrilled by that but I was too old to be
thrilled but it's kind of cool when
someone you grew up watching maybe knows
a little bit I and that's so pathetic to
even admit but yeah I was like ah thanks
Chris because it's part of why we do
this is we're still insecure yeah but
but hundred percent were and I hope I
know it's on my eyelid area I hope I
always not hold on in the fact that I
don't like myself that much yeah I'll
lose my funny but it was also cool
because I think actors know that they
can't do what we do do you think that
you would lose your funny if you if you
had a higher self-esteem I mean III I
think I have come to a point where I do
like myself now I stop beating myself up
but I wonder if I would have been as
desperate to be heard as desperate to be
significant if I really was if I liked
myself and I was I said we had peace of
mind I was at ease I don't know one
[ __ ] comic worth their salt who feels
that way about themselves yeah a [ __ ]
comic and that's why I like [ __ ]
comics are you happy with yourself it's
a struggle I think I've been in therapy
for a long time I haven't been in it for
a little while right now but I haven't
been it's I think that's it for whatever
reason like New York comics like we're
all in therapy man like there's so much
it's the Woody Allen it is what what did
you what have you gleaned from therapy I
[ __ ] my adopted Asian stepdaughter and
I'm kidding somebody Alan
what I think you know have you figured
it did you have any like aha moments
about sure yeah you know I had a tough
relationship with my biological father
and I think it helped a lot like and it
showed how selfish she was and it helped
me avoid you know maybe going down a
similar path
yeah tough Davidoff was in therapy you
know dove sure I love that it's like my
best friend usually that's one of my
favorite people on the planet he had a
recent balance that there was so funny
man we talked about maybe it wasn't that
reason but he talked about his couples
therapy that therapy was so good [ __ ]
a monster cool guy and he said to me he
goes yeah I went to therapy and I
figured some stuff I go what he goes
well you know I mean the therapist after
a while looked at me and said you you
feel like you have a right to exist
and I was like I mean not really I guess
when push comes to shove no I was like
that's a [ __ ] breakthrough right
there that's rough I mean he he was
serious my therapist I used to do a joke
away and I said my third good time a
relationship he said you tend to pursue
damaged people and then try to help them
and I said are you too you too
that's a great answer we uh no I'm
definitely I definitely was in it for a
long time I saw a lot of different
therapists and it was it was it was
helpful for me but yeah I mean a lot of
time you just don't you just don't feel
good when you leave I don't yeah I
stopped going yeah I just didn't find it
helpful I really I'm pretty I'm the
other I'm gonna say this though I'm a
really happy person
yeah I'm not even good energy or easy to
talk yeah my ex said told me I was dark
but I don't think so I feel so lucky and
I always feel happy and I think that's
because I have my serotonin levels are
just naturally at an eighth you exercise
a lot of that problem I exercise like a
[ __ ] animal
yeah I never miss a [ __ ] day really
no I got you working with later I want
to sit you're gonna take me in with your
hands really yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
you can take you take me in with your
hands I'll give it a shot yeah I want to
feel that bear hug movie doing the guy
yeah yeah I moved this way then he as he
put his weight there I I need picton I
don't know if I did it right I just
think like maintenance on your like
mental and then physical or so like
especially what we do man we travel on
the road all the time and like my body
oh I bag problems all the time so I just
I always I'm trying to do stuff I can
solve your back problems with [ __ ]
exercises if you think really I'll solve
your back I'll solve your I'm gonna take
you up on that today to really do it
[ __ ] yeah what do you do for your back
well first of all what do you [ __ ] do
so I call evolution eyes you physically
what do I do
I don't do much man I I think muscle
relaxers everyone else in the area yeah
I I drink alcohol after I take the
muscle this is all very new your i what
do I do
no I do die I fly I mean you know go we
fly a lot it hurts man just it's it's
rough so well you got a-you got to build
the muscles people think he is stretched
you got to build the stabilizer muscles
yeah I I never knew this until I became
a frico I even follow web
Instagram like squat University I'm
phenomena me too for different reason
for different reasons and then like dr.
sim Pinelli and I got all these
therapists physical therapists that I
follow and they it's a it's it's amazing
yeah do the exercises and and pain-free
you believe it or not a lot of your back
problems starting your your glutes your
ass I believe it yeah we're gonna work
your ass yeah dude what else that what
what so you're sports fan I'm a big
Knicks fan I love the Knicks I'm a big
basketball fan I like also Isiah Thomas
the other day really yeah at a party
yeah walk by me and I went he crippled
my Knicks for about five years I know he
did he [ __ ] us so that's so mad
nice Claire I mean he's one of the best
done right he's like a little taller
than me maybe it was like great athlete
coming through great athlete comes
through he goes no not me I go yeah you
yeah one percenter one of the best I
mean he also you know it's crazy you
know the story about him not being on
the dream team right no this is [ __ ]
first I've mg
hated and Michael Jordan [ __ ] hated
me why because the bad boy pistons were
so dirty and then so they were so dirty
they wouldn't like just Bill Laimbeer
and [ __ ] I bill and beyond my sports
show on dirtiest [ __ ] ever like
Larry Bird won't talk to him to this day
I kind of leave I respect how crazy he
is but I'm like I want no part of you
dude so MJ hated them Bird hated them
and then what cuz they just they foul
there wasn't basketball it was so I mean
they were incredible and Lambie was a
skilled player but they would just try
to injure you they were so dirty and
Jordan then can't finally came back the
year he overcame the Pistons was the
year he kind of became MJ beats the
Pistons and the playoffs and they all
walked off the floor and wouldn't shake
his hand they were bad sports too so one
of the things one of the big moments
with Isaiah is so this is kind of cool
that Isaiah there but also [ __ ] up
when you know Dennis Rodman was on the
Pistons he was kind of nuts and they
still he's still nuts he's in [ __ ]
lost something it's like a custody
custody of a son or another thing was
you know Isaiah after they got
eliminated by the Celtics Rodman said
that people only talked about Larry Bird
cause he's white and he's not that good
and Isaiah heard that and was like he
said that and he goes yeah he's right I
don't think he believed that Isaiah I
think almost and he knew he knew that
Larry Bird was great but he but he sided
with his teammate and that's when the
Pistons came together so it was like
[ __ ] up he did that but it's kind of
like I got your back for any who said
that about Burt Rodman Wow so then so
then i MJ hated him I think Bird hated
him and then Magic heads they were cool
now but they had a falling out so they
want I don't think anyone wanted and MJ
wouldn't play on the dream team if Isiah
did so Isiah should have been on the
dream team and he was and I think it
[ __ ] with him like tille is damn it's
dark man cuz I'm Artie Lange said the
described Michael Jordan the best way
I've ever heard anybody describe a
person yeah cuz for his wealth will to
win and his competitiveness
already Lange said if Michael Jordan had
been on the Titanic
it wouldn't have some [ __ ] holes
Artie Lange the best he's heard Chris
Rock would say about Steph Curry there's
one of the best ones I heard you guys
Steph Curry is Allen Iverson with two
parents that's amazing such a good line
it's a great line and it's
true yeah it's amazing yeah I didn't
realize that Korea is the greatest
three-point shooter of all time it's
insane
yeah you're not probably maybe not like
standstill but like off the dribble I
don't even think there's a question so
he can create his own no one could do
that back in the day how tall is he 6-4
6-3 maybe always looks smaller kind of
Jack now he's so well behaved he's so
like good and every yeah well his dad
was wasn't that a coach his dad played
for the Hornets he was a great shooter
to Dell curry and his day I mean you
hear those stories man you hear those
stories about like athlete red perfect
fundamentals that's what it was
absolutely here you go his brother's a
good player too Seth he's not a star
like Steph is but he's like us he's a
solid NBA shooter so anybody who makes
it to the NBA you know anybody who makes
it I mean look he played a Duke I mean
these guys could ball yeah it's a big
deal and and he really yeah Steph
Curry's a beast he's it's like he was so
loved and then the Warriors kind of
became too good but if that's not his
[ __ ] fault they got Kate he's married
I think we're in the street as he
probably cheats I think they all
probably do but why would you guys with
girls aren't throwing themselves at it's
not his Instagram DMS aren't getting
[ __ ] let me throws a lot of pictures
up with his wife which is a red flag to
me I think when pro athletes are like
this is how much I love my wife I'm like
yeah but how about it's like I don't
think that's like me posting a picture
with like guys can do it I mean yeah but
when you look like that you're a young
man and see I've seen the kind of women
that that are available to those guys
yeah and it's well until you've walked
in a man's shoes and I'm in that man's
shoes hold your [ __ ] judgments just
ever because it's it's so weird what
happens to guys like that she's a
[ __ ] beauty look maybe he loves her
maybe I think he does love her good I
hope you know but the point is I don't
know man that guy can get he can get me
and I'm straight you let him [ __ ] you I
make out with him probably if I was
drunk he'd [ __ ] you he'd probably [ __ ]
you so he'd [ __ ] you and he'd pull out
from outside and then shoot from you
from like 30 feet
accurate ESL accurate is right [ __ ]
in the left eye you just call it left
eye we shouldn't be talking about Steph
Curry this way it's much of a class act
he's a class act and I I will say I
respect him a ton I respect all the
Warriors man clay Steph Steve Kerr's an
awesome coach dream on the [ __ ] and you
know what they they pissed me off so
much because they're so good and right
now that the worst team in the league
cuz Steph's injured Clay's injured so
they're gonna get a sick draft pick and
they're gonna come back better than ever
next year and it [ __ ] infuriates
Rondo look at LeBron he looks like a
velociraptor yeah like Steph Curry's
chocolate avatar you can't you can't
guard LeBron he's 35 and he's still top
335 still top three I would enclose old
I think he is he's every bit of 260 I
said nice to Carlos Boozer on the plane
Carlos said we're the same size do you
understand he's just much faster than
I'm stronger than all of us
yeah dude and cause boosters is a
[ __ ] house he's a house yeah you look
at him and you're like oh well that's
why oh you're a prophet I'm an actor
I'm a piece of [ __ ] and you're that was
born sick say it's not our fault
I suck I mean I suck he's you know I
want to look like that yeah whose was a
big he's [ __ ] geez look at those arms
he's a big man I'm 60 yes my gosh I love
the I love the NBA so much it's it's
such a great time for the NBA right now
yeah it really is
hey you know you did tell me that Boozer
told me that Kobe was very hard to get
close to absolute like he and and and
I've heard that from other players I
mean to out Boozer but you know he said
Kobe was a guy who would never go out
with them like he he just and I and I
said I was like that guy was so singular
he wasn't interested in people he was
interested in being great I'm sure he
loved his family it's such a tragedy but
that was what was great about Kobe is
that he he was the dude that he made
everyone else better like his greatness
rubbed off on others like on Team USA
but the same way Jordan did or
a little less I think he was the Jordan
of that generation I think no one will
be Jordan because Jordan was Jordan but
but CO and no one will be as good as
Jordan really at some will say LeBron is
better because he's a better passer and
he's bigger but you know Kobe had
Jordan's whale on his heart I think and
on Team USA he it was he had a young
LeBron a young Dwayne way too young
Carmelo and they all had their best year
right after playing on Team USA with
Kobe because they saw his habits and
like they'd be like oh we're gonna go
out and be like I'm not going out I'm
waking up at 5:00 a.m. to [ __ ] shoot
and work out do you know what I what I
was reminded of when it came to Coe
because I'm not a basketball fan I don't
know a lot about this stuff but Kobe was
always a guy I saw hitting the three
points or whatever it had to be right
but I didn't realize that he also won
the slam dunk calm as a rookie which I
so I was like oh you also can do that
but you didn't even do that in your in
your career he's primarily a shooter I
mean he was a scorer he really never had
yeah he was like a will to win score I
mean he what Carlos said to me I think
it was him and said he would he'd try to
wake up early earlier than Kobe and beat
him at you know like and Kobe to always
be there before him 5:30 in morning
mamas mentality that I mean Kobe III as
a basketball fan like I feel like Kobe
was almost like the Ric Flair of the NBA
well you just could he was like a heel
for so long I feel like even if you
hated him you loved him you loved to
hate him yeah because he was hit most of
my friends didn't the world Knicks fans
in New Yorker and they just hated him
but they would always be like you just
can't argue with the guy you my points
in a game my friend Stavros always said
you couldn't ignore him I mean that's
that's just the truth I mean he he was
he was the toughest cover in the NBA and
he was just so [ __ ] good and then he
kind of is cool to watch it he was such
a ruthless competitor in his prime and
then at the end of his career he became
kind of a mentor to so many young guys
so you see like the instagrams of these
E players who were like that was like my
my guy like everyone felt they had a
connection deal he [ __ ] Jeremy Lin up
he's like I don't want to play on the
same quarters him yeah he was like he
was calling teammates calling I don't
want that dude on the team yeah he's
like I'm not playing on the court with
him and and Jeremy Lin was like this
thing he was looking up to him and
Jeremy [ __ ] Jeremy Lin up
I've heard lost Jeremy Lin dude he he'd
come to sell a plan he's planned for the
Beijing Ducks right now he Jeremy Lin's
a cool dude he'd come to the cellar he
was a really nice guy always and he
hooked me up with tickets to games and
stuff he was so nice and I think he
noticed when he played for the Nets I'd
only hit him up for Knicks nets tickets
and he'd be like he only hit me up twice
a year you know but uh he was really
good right dude when he I remember he's
such a classy guy I remember the night
when Lynn sandy was going down which is
like the best moment of my last 20 years
the next fan he just went off on the
Lakers he dropped thirty eight so Kobe
before the game said I don't know who he
is and I don't know if it was on purpose
to [ __ ] with him but after the game
bashed Jeremy Lin like you think he
knows he weren't now and he goes you'll
have to ask him like you very classy
always yeah but that was the night that
Whitney Houston died I remember that
because I remember someone tweeted how
long they play together they only played
together a season I think I remember
that it was a night Whitney Houston died
and someone tweeted holy [ __ ] Whitney
Houston's dead that's Lynn Sain it was
like the night but uh how tall is he
it's like six four yeah but dude he got
Jeremy Lin's cool cuz he got like slept
on you know he just got like profile it
as an e63 i'ma but he was like an Asian
do so he would [ __ ] dudes up in college
as a Harvard player you know he played
at Harbor because he didn't get any d1
offers so then he'd [ __ ] up UConn and
like Kemba Walker and like great players
and they'd be like add to flu cuz he's
Asian
like they legit were scheduled legit
racist yeah sure it's insane well you
just you just did you have to as an
Asian player there are a great deal of
assumptions you have to come get over
being a black man and I was like I don't
you know I was like I don't think things
are as prejudiced in a black dude um who
listens to the podcast said hey dude let
me tell you something I have my PhD or
he's a doctor and he goes it's not like
that what it is when I walk into a room
I have to overcome a bunch of
assumptions that are made about me and
until you've lived that it's way too
subtle to explain but it does take a lot
of effort it does it is very difficult
not to have a little bit of a chip on
your shoulder yeah you know so those are
the things that as a as a why
landowner I just taught he really he
really though yeah he Lin had an awesome
run so he mean yeah I'm a fan of his
forever you know yeah let's do some
current events man so let me see if I
have my rate cons I don't but I'm going
to tell you this I'm gonna say it out
loud I was sent these rate cons and I
don't use my ear pods anymore
I use my rate cons couple reasons one
they stay in my ears - I think the sound
is better I couldn't be happier with
them three I think the battery lasts
longer so I'm a fan of rate cons I don't
know Ray J I don't know much about it
but I I'm a fan I think they're
excellent
the e25 is what I have that's the best
one yet with six hours of playtime six
hours seamless bluetooth pairing III
pair with my iPhone more bass a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise-isolating fit it's pretty awesome
I use it when I work out I use them when
I'm just walking around they're my go-to
they're my go-to so you know I don't
know apples got some catching up to do
in my opinion and all earbuds are air
recon earbuds are also stylish and
discreet they made there's no dangling
wires or stems they just look they just
fit in your ear perfectly so it was
founded by Ray J and somebody's like
Snoop Dogg and cardi B whatever but I
don't really care about any of that I
think it's a really good product so now
it's time to get the latest and greatest
from recon get 15% of your order at buy
rake on RA Y Co end comm /t fat K buy
rake on comm /t fat K and you'll get 15%
off rake on wireless earbuds I own them
I use them they're awesome guys
sometimes you need a bar okay and you
want that bar to be keto friendly and
you want that bar to be plant-based and
you want that par to be delicious
okay anybody like chocolate chip cookie
dough because if you don't you're
probably not American or you've never
had it
alright either way ki eats bars are keto
friendly they're seriously delicious
they're made with whole ingredients like
almonds they've got all kinds of flavors
give it a shot everybody I know I've
actually have not yet tried one but
everybody I know who has speaks of them
with glowing reviews I'm going to eat
some so that I can tell you exactly how
I feel but my feeling is after talking
to three people of eating them they
think they are unbelievable
they're sweet and I guess with this
fda-approved keto sugar called Lu lohse
so they taste like they're really sweet
but it's but it's keto and it's not the
kind of sugar that spikes your blood
level not Sookie eats calm / spider
trike eats bars for free three bars for
free and with free shipping do it so it
is currently Black History Month and
there is a man in Iowa who is recently
arrested because he kidnapped a woman
who multiple media sites would not
classify what race she was in but it's
assumed that she's a white lady so this
guy kidnapped her for nine hours forced
her to watch the roots to make sure that
she understood racism better and then
it's not explained how she escaped or if
she was let go
she should force him to watch misery to
understand holy [ __ ] yeah he's a kid
everyone forcing him to watch rules to
understand her racism damn what what did
she do that made her just kidnapped a
random woman and he made her sit down
and watch the entire miniseries with
with him for nine hours and every time
she would kind of fidget in her seat and
try to get up he said that he would then
scatter her body parts in Chicago on a
like a very popular Highway and so she
was basically intimidated to sit down
and just watch this entire miniseries
and she eventually was released energy
that yeah she
fortunately like nothing happened to her
she ended up reporting it to the police
and they found they found him but
they're still so confused why he decided
he's obviously crazy obviously but that
is the most bizarre [ __ ] I've ever heard
in my life that's great that is you know
no they don't so is he
rested we don't know first arrive first
an orange dude he's probably arrested
there's nothing in the picture get
arrested we are waiting for him to get
charged he's out of his mind out of his
mind
you never think that that's gonna happen
to you forced to watch roots easy
laughing he's laughing is he's watching
Diff'rent Strokes in that picture
I heard that um these Navy SEALs their
instructor they were all freezing on a
rock I don't know if this is true
they're freezing on a rock and and he
goes the first one to get a hard-on if
one of you guys get a hard-on you can
come back in but if not you're sitting
out on this [ __ ] the water and
everybody's like totally frozen so
they're all trying to get like try back
in and get warm cuz he was trying to
[ __ ] with our minds oh that's nuts so
that's kind of like that [ __ ] cry be
moved by and stop being racist yeah how
long is roots how many episodes there is
some miniseries so I'm guessing anywhere
so it's like nine nine yeah our each
that's a long that's that's a while and
it's assumed that he made that that
woman watched the 1970s version not the
more recent one I remember seeing that
counts Bernie I remember seeing it as a
kid it moved the [ __ ] out of me I was
just like I'm her sending my grandpa why
why would they do that why would they do
that to those people if I was that woman
I was kidnapped I'd be like can we watch
the Green Book I want like a white race
as a movie we just it's such a good
series I really said why you know I
remember it being so all right next one
okay have you guys seen this clip going
around Twitter oh they're gonna pause
this real quick you guys have seen this
Mike this problem yeah this is the guy
he's on punching the back of a wooden
seat
what's going on here right this guy's on
the seat with that does not recline near
the back and then she's reclining into
him and he's punching her seat like you
know it's rude to proclaim in to me what
I can't become but when I can't recline
back myself so a lot of people are
divided some people think he's an
[ __ ] for punching her seat and some
people think that she's an [ __ ] for
reclining the seat well she has rights
per class see she brought her back like
seat number one number two so she paid
her money number two three you're not
allowed to do that you're harassing some
so she's your your your your you're
actually being unlawful there are rules
against that you're you're physically
essentially physically harassing whether
it's assault or not it's different story
but that's definitely physical
harassment yeah you know so he's a piece
of douchebag I would never do that I'd
be like this is my shitty seat you move
back you you you know you've a client so
what maybe you could ask hey do you mind
I'm my I have no room do you mind not
doing that apparently he did ask cool
moments before he actually it was the
part in the flight where they had food
out and so he asked oh can you put your
seat up so I can eat and she said yes
and once the food was taken away she
then reclined her seat again and he got
really angry and started to punch her
seat she said that she called a
stewardess over and she kind of rolled
her eyes at the woman and offered him a
complimentary rum for his for his like
inconvenience give him more alcohol he
said yeah he's a good drinker and once
she started to record he stops punching
the sea and just started kind of tapping
at it the way he is in the video I think
that American Airlines is wrong on this
I think that guy's a [ __ ] and I think
he's also a woman she's also an older
woman or she's a woman a woman so she's
a smaller brain she doesn't know how but
she's a woman like how about being a
gentleman you [ __ ] baby that's [ __ ]
up a shame she should've done that [ __ ]
like that both they're both kind of like
douchey both of them I don't know man I
was reclining to someone a woman does
that waiting I'm gonna be like she's
like I'm gonna be like she's got a
reclinable scene I just I got a [ __ ] in
the deal I'm lady bad I might say
something I'm not gonna hit her so that
was stupid to you because he's being a
panhead
I would [ __ ] you know what I would do
I'd slit his [ __ ] everybody on the
plane and it would be on him cuz I can't
have witnesses and then I gotta delete
her phone and find out what her first I
got to find out what her passcode is so
I can I delete it from the cloud I'd be
annoyed that like you're giving him
friendly you giving him free rum he's
punching him why is he getting free
alcohol she worried and ROM what are you
a pirate mom on a plane I have some rum
matey
Hey alright next one ok so a couple days
ago uh Dwyane Wade went on to Ellen and
talked about how his child
Ziya who was born as a man as a male
named Zion came out to him and Gabrielle
Union his wife saying that he wants to
be referred to as Ziya and used the
pronouns
she and her and Dwyane Wade basically
said that it's his job as a parent to
basically let his kids be who they want
to be and that's all he really said akka
was I think yesterday night rapper boozy
badass went online and he made a whole
video about saying if you want your son
to be gay let him be gay but what if
he's sixteen one day falls in love with
a girl don't chop off his dick don't cut
off well first of all you're not allowed
to in this country that so there are a
lot of misconceptions about if your
child is transgender you legally are not
allowed to do these things you're not
allowed to do physically altering you
can't physically alter their biology
until they are of consent link till
they're 18 hmm so you know this is not
an easy thing for Dwayne Wade and his
wife it's obviously a very sense of
thing their child reads social media so
this is really hard for them and for the
kid I was like I always you know we said
some stuff on this podcast I think it
was Brendon I was talking and and I
think we have to be you know you have to
always be really sensitive to this stuff
because these people listen to stuff you
know yeah I don't know man I think it's
very hard it's got to be very hard
because they obviously love the [ __ ] out
of their kid of course and I'm
protective of their kid and when people
come on and talk about their child you
know yeah like hey man I don't give a
[ __ ] what your point of view is and I
understand he's
probably coming from a good place but I
don't know man uh well you know you
gotta also know that you don't you don't
really have the right you were not
allowed to do that you know yeah the
name of the give the kid a Zion I think
that Zion Williamson of the Pelican
should get a sex change and join the
WNBA and just [ __ ] everybody up like you
want a man style yeah no I think I I
love Dwayne Wade I'm like a huge fan and
I think he actually seems like a
progressive great dude so you know loves
his child main thing is just as a parent
I I I can understand how difficult all
of it is when your child is being talked
but how many pro athlete is that we
talked about it but how many pro
athletes are even coming out and being
that you know being that supportive of
their kid and there are other athletes
who have kids like this so for Dwayne
Wade to be that openly supportive for
other I think it helps other kids why
sure it's pretty cool than athlete on
that magnitude is doing hundred-percent
that's good yeah I'm now that we even
spoke about it we were being flippant
about it I don't think we weren't being
insulting but flippant and then it
doesn't matter it's also important to
note that Dwyane Wade never said
anything about like his child going
undergoing any type of surgery he's just
talking about how the child wanted to be
referred to us and a lot of people also
had a lot of backlash with this rapper
because he has seven children that he
does not take care of oh wow
how many seven there you go what he's
got seven kids no kids
does not take care of who's stupid
[ __ ] and you shut your mouth
then shut your mouth Anita's hung about
doing an irresponsible piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] anybody who does it I
got no time for that [ __ ] yeah you
you're a [ __ ] too you don't take care
of your seven kids [ __ ] what's his name
Busey badass seven kids you piece of
[ __ ] you don't take care of kids you're
a failure [ __ ] you I don't give a [ __ ]
what the reason I don't care if you
didn't have a dad go [ __ ] yourself
fatherlessness huge problem [ __ ] you he
seems like a tough guy so this is just
brian saying
how about the kids how do they out of
your kids feel look father your kids
[ __ ] yeah take care of your kids [ __ ]
anybody does a [ __ ] anybody doesn't
think are the kids is a piece of [ __ ]
and part of the problem I got zero you
know what I would do if I was provide
the authority I would take that
[ __ ] back guess what dude you're
paying for all your kids and they're
living with you and if you have a
problem I'll put you in jail forever go
[ __ ] yourself
this is that this is the biggest problem
facing United States fathers who have a
bunch of kids and don't take care of
them it is shitty yeah I am good you
leave it up to the mom so you got a
single mom go [ __ ] yourself
I doubt it at all one mom no it's not
it's it's he's probably spread it out ya
know that should I mean I guarantee it's
seven different one of the first jokes
ever wrote about my biological father
was uh my friend is your biological
father a good person and I said if he
were I probably wouldn't refer to him as
my biological so tried a great dad who
raised me but I lucked out so you know
kids need that you don't you can't do
that
I I is that him that's Busey badass
right there yep and he is well known for
the song back that ass up the remix he's
older bro you're old I know put me down
this is true I might be being unfair
because I don't know you just told me
that so I don't know if that's true yeah
so if it is true then he's I'm sure he's
yeah if if it's true he looks sad you
know it looks likes crying there I don't
know it's more know maybe he's a good
person if I if I'm if you don't if you
do take care of those kids I'm sorry if
you don't you're a [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
and I hope you die clear yeah that's and
I stand by that okay this is a really
quick gross one a woman is shared a clip
of herself soaking in her bathtub and in
the bathtub it's filled with water and
hot cheetos
oh well it's gonna hurt hot cheetos girl
no this is someone else what would what
is the purpose of this she said she was
helping her friend with some sort of
project and they were filming in a
bathtub where they filled it with hot
cheetos all right I don't know what it's
for but a lot of people are very angry
about this
oh just doing that huh is that that
can't be refreshing no looks gross huh
also I don't feel like that's good for
also you're a better video I know so
quick so I need so needed this after
stress hopefully she's covering her
private oh that's my first thought like
yeah might that might seep inside that
can't feel good
alright ready for another one this is
pretty crazy this is in the UK and this
woman right here is a violinist in her
50s and you know since she's a violin
she's been playing since was like 10
years old and she's in she's part of the
an orchestra in the UK she had a tumor
in her brain and the surgeons woke her
up during the surgery to make sure that
when they removed the tumor they're not
actually messing with her hands the way
she plays violin so she was playing well
then as they're doing surgery kind of
brain surgery right there
I'm like I don't even know how it's
possible that they could do it while
they're doing surgery on her brain to
keep her you know awake and I don't know
what do I know
without yeah that was pretty crazy I
know it's boozy badass yeah you got me
all fired up by the fighting stuff no
but you're very very hard on dads that
don't care take care of the kids no I
have no time yes other lessness in this
country is a huge problem
all right next one apparently people
have software now that can mimic like
your voice or your mom's voice or my
voice or whatever and they'll call you
and scam you out of money so they'll
take a little audio sample of your voice
and pretend like it's your mom or your
dad or whatever app needing you guys to
wire the money
yeah so it's actually working now that
software is that good well this is the
Better Business Bureau actually warning
the public of it they say it's for
companies now but it could be also like
regular people to you get those IRS scam
calls with it all this I got all that I
got one recently with the guys like it's
just how [ __ ] annoying they are the
guy goes he goes you're in a lot of
trouble that's like that's how the
government talks and oh [ __ ] I called I
called it I call the numbers dude always
call him back yeah I was just Indian guy
I'm like yeah and then I finally got
this one law firm told me they had some
tax thing that they wanted I was like so
let me guess you guys want to do my
attack that they were tell me I might be
in violation of something and it was
just a scam and the girl did kind of
like she was working for them and I go
do it so why why are you doing this it's
such a [ __ ] scam what she says she
goes wow wow yeah well dude it's like
huh you know one of the cons they pull
now is they asked you to go to the
drugstore and get like Google Play gift
cards or like baskin-robbins gift cards
and you buy them and you read off the
back of the code because that way
there's no paper trail yeah they're
[ __ ] you if you think that's the
government at that point you're a
[ __ ] idiot you probably deserve it
it's usually like old old people
Nigerians were doing amazing amazing
scams though they had offices they had
actual cash that was that was um
counterfeit I mean they they would do
all kinds of they would do they even had
like bills that would look so real and
then they would turn blue or something
like a type of dye
I mean this guy jumped out a window cuz
he lost all his money not so sad but I'm
two million dollars into this project
but they were like totally [ __ ] I heard
that there was like delivering or
sending checks to celebrities like big
checks for thousands of dollars and you
can cash and it's actually real but then
once you cash it they have like control
over it somehow you're baking something
out ya know what they do is that I had a
guy on for the longest time and he he
said sir you've won this sweepstakes but
you have to pay the taxes on it and the
minute you pay the taxes we are
authorized to release the cheque so I'm
like okay okay this amazing okay so what
where do I send the money how is it I
said I $2,300 and I go okay where einem
was in Jamaica okay I'm gonna send it
and I go okay I sent it where as I go I
don't know I sent the money wait hold on
saying now it's back it didn't go what
were what do you give me the I had the
guy running all over to make up and
finally at the end of it I was like it's
not there yes
no I guess mom for like a whole day I go
I go I go well then well then can you
have you checked your ass I said
something like that why don't you check
your butt or whatever bah bah bah
all right here's the next one the Jeff
Bezos is donating ten billion dollars
like he's starting some sort of company
to help the environment climate change
well he's awesome but there's critics of
him from Amazon their own employees but
that stayed anonymous saying like he's
already like wooing other companies like
oil companies which are causing climate
change right are you know-
it's impossible not to be Amazon and not
cause climate I know he [ __ ] that the
guy is they like not pay federal taxes I
mean they've got some well he's get away
with some crazy [ __ ]
he's about us
that's the way handled the dick-pic
situation you know where he was like put
it out I'll [ __ ] it he's like that was
his whole thing like all right I guess
he's got a decent piece well no I sue
you
yeah good luck keeping up with Jeff
Bezos yeah he's not even become Jeff
Bezos because he's a [ __ ] the [ __ ] off
yeah the Beast yeah I think he's I know
a guy who knows him well and says that
he's very [ __ ] special and does want
to make the world a better player
he said he might had a cousin who said
he might be the savior yeah what they
say because she's that he's really cool
oh yeah I think I know a guy who wrote a
book who's writing it was written two
books on really on Silicon Valley the
[ __ ] his name who is the one who is
the woman who is called I am called to
the amateur bringing up called coffee
amateur yeah and the cult in the amateur
it's about how YouTube like everybody
can just be in anything yeah Andrew keen
yeah Andrew keen said he Bezos might be
the one guy because he knows all those
guys who is the woman though who ripped
the blood company who ripped everyone
off then Oh such a great book was
hilarious such a great [ __ ]
documentary what was her name again is
from Sara knows I know them yeah they're
on earth yes Elizabeth Holmes yeah
her fake voice with a gross deep voices
or voice but if you just dress the part
you can get that far if you're confident
and you just dress the part
holy [ __ ] yeah face she looked
attractive but they're not attractive
but then attractive while she I couldn't
a lot of weight in her face I guess or
her looks I mean that's my Photoshop she
was a strange strange one
yes sir real like just kind of full of
[ __ ] yeah but her family you know she's
got some DC and I I have we have friends
that know her family and you know
they're trying to help her and stuff but
it's like come on man come on so weird
to be like we're so proud of you you
made this company then like oh you
ripped off everybody you're a [ __ ]
horrible first she may have been
somebody who was just trying to fake
until she made it so she really believed
she was gonna pull
this was probably she was just thought
she was trying to be Steve Jobs she was
dressed like him she wore the same thing
every day she had she had this whole
image of herself and it didn't work
she's too young she just wasn't didn't
have the goods look at her now look at
her there and that picture where she's
doing a deposition yeah it doesn't look
good well it's not a good time not a
good time it's usually not your best
photo the deposition now what do another
one one more Q more all right so how do
you guys follow NASCAR I know I don't
all right well there was this crazy
crash that happened Oh No and then I'll
show you what happened here Oh oh my god
when the air flipped got hit by another
car and then sliding on the roof and
there's fire obviously yeah they said
this is the closest thing to win Dale
Earnhardt crashed and died Jimmy the guy
died no so after this crash he was in
serious condition Vicky and this was on
this what 17th it's incredible that this
that people can survive this yeah what
technology that's easy it was because of
they'll Earnhardt crash they developed
technologies to actually save this guy
oh yeah now is he gonna be all right
yeah so he was in serious condition his
name is Ryan Newman and then look at him
here he was walking home with his
daughters already what a badass are you
kidding me he has no shoes on for some
reason but yeah well he's probably a
little banged up right definitely will
banged up my store yeah they don't they
don't show that he's holding a cup of
gin right there before drives them in
Jesus what a bad market for him okay
especially those two beautiful daughters
yeah what a [ __ ] tough guy does okay
you what man back on the old track you
know what I mean back on I have a barely
a driver's license so I can't really
well we're gonna fight after this but
I'm gonna fix her back first I hope so
whoa this is the last one what Steven
Spielberg's daughter has come out as a
porn star and I believe it's his like
adopted daughter Stanley is that coming
out
we thought she was Jewish using that
progressive a term with everything now
is they come out as trans I've come out
as person who sucks no she's so she's a
porn star yeah apparently snot like her
hit and bottom is her choice yeah that's
what she's saying do you think I don't
do you think it's possible to be I mean
I'm sure there's some happy porn stars
but no no no you don't think so
well I think it's I think it's an
extreme way to live and it's it's I
don't know I don't think it's good I
mean if just my opinion I I like I I
I think we're damaging her own way as
comics too but I just think they're like
[ __ ] I wouldn't want my my kid well I do
if I had a kid you know well I've tried
to figure out what's I watch it so I
don't want to be a hypocrite
I actually don't watch it anymore at all
yeah I have watched it in the past how
long have you how long were you off porn
years what yeah good for you it's not
because I'm I just doesn't turn me on
because I look at it differently and I
don't know I just it doesn't I don't get
off on it something happened it's like
you know that click that you know but I
don't judge anybody for doing because I
have watch player but I am I think it's
if you're gonna pay a price like you do
for everything but there's something
there's something I don't I would
imagine it probably doesn't work out for
most people right and why maybe that's a
better question why I don't know I don't
wanna I don't wanna I don't know you had
also Karen she had like a good life and
everything was perfect for I don't like
to I don't like it serves a really of
the it's a multi-billion dollar industry
for a reason everybody watch everybody
does yeah so to say that it's you know I
I eat burgers I wouldn't want my kid to
slaughter cows maybe a boxer it's a
skill set and you become really good but
you're gonna have brain damage right
right and if you're a porn star I don't
know if it's a skill set it just
requires a damn mindset not a skill set
it requires to eat you to have a sir
biology and then just to be willing to
[ __ ] if you so many [ __ ] camera you'd
think it was a skill set because it's
that I can't do it what yeah but that
that might be true like where you're
into it but I think we all are wary of
something that seems like they're using
their own body in a way that would
usually in most circumstances and
societies and in history be considered
unnatural just even though sex is
unnatural we all know even they know
that in for one reason or another when
you're getting paid it's being put on
camera something that's almost always
very intimate is now being put on
display that's extreme for whatever
reason that would be considered a
different and extreme way of living and
even though we all watch it somehow we
all have a deep judgement about it
including them
yeah I've talked to enough four stars
about that so I don't know I don't know
I don't know either
I don't but I I don't like I feel like a
hypocrite if I say anything bad about it
yeah if you watch it don't say that you
know if you watch it you're part of it
you're all we're all part of it all of
us are yeah maybe they're the ones who
are at least open and honest about it
that's a good point yeah but I still I
still think that there's something that
there's something the way we talk about
I love football too but like there's
something harmful yeah that is yeah but
footballs also different yeah well both
the skillset football you make a lot of
money football you have a life
afterwards
there's something self-destructive maybe
about about it we all know that
ultimately it's just not gonna be it's
probably not gonna work out and horn and
in some ways like we talked about like
it's kind of like it's hard to if if
you're young and you do point it's hard
to segue that into another career that's
what I mean yeah but but it does serve a
purpose we all watch it yeah it's like I
never would I've known women who had sex
for money who went to a phase where they
were doing that I [ __ ] would never
judge that yeah because you know what so
you found some really rich dude is
willing to pay you a thousand three
thousand bucks to have sex with you and
you were either attracted to him or you
weren't but you at the time had to pay
your rent
look man I never been there I don't
what the [ __ ] but I that's as old as
time and they're serving a purpose and
and for both parties so you know comedy
and pornos it's like the two oldest game
is man you know yeah it is I've always
felt weirdly protective over the porn
people that I've known like I always
want to try to [ __ ] them they're usually
nice people
oh yeah well like I knew a lot of Evans
yeah and I I [ __ ] love her III think
I did a podcast with her a lot Evans was
a badass old-school porn star yeah but I
[ __ ] loved everything about Alana I
still loved her I think she's just a I
love her all I remember her she's a
[ __ ] like I follow a couple porn
stars just cuz I've met him before and
they were nice so I just follow a couple
of them on Twitter and stuff and it's so
weird to be scroll everyone else I
follow on Twitter as a comic so it's so
weird just because just post porn so
I'll be in a grocery store like joke
joke someone taking two [ __ ] at the
same time that's so weird to see
outdoors you know tonight I'm usually
home and prepared for seeing this it is
there is something jarring about it but
I also feel the same way we would like
they they also seem to weirdly
understand comedy in a way like they
understand us in a way because I think
they like people that are also kind of
on their own and loners and kind of
almost like freelance type professionals
and kind of bear themselves in another
way so I do feel a weird kinship with
him at the same time I think a lot of
Evans like I actually got to know her I
would like periodically just call and
say hi and she's just that I like
everything about her and I don't know I
I she was in a relationship she had kids
and she'd say I don't know you know I
went through a thing but she was as
normal as anybody I've ever [ __ ] met
and still is yeah and you know I feel
the same way about Kira I feel the same
way about I knew kailani lay a little
bit for a while she was gorgeous another
old school girl she was like just you'd
fall in love with her I mean you know
dude he's a bit so I don't know hey
Nicole Aniston dates my buddy Stevie and
I've never you know I've spent enough
time with them where where
he's gorgeous you don't get any sexual
vibe from her she's doing her thing and
she's in this relationship so she seems
very cool to me so I don't know man
yeah I guess I just I guess yeah I don't
know yeah I'm not gonna judge it I'm not
I'm yeah that's fair everybody watches
it all over the [ __ ] world
yeah yeah so what's up maybe it maybe
it's us maybe the fact that we have a
judgement about it
maybe that's what keeps them out in the
outskirts and as outlaws maybe that's
what it is
porn is porn is weirdly accepting and
I've always said that you know that
they're more progressive and in terms
were like they don't call them in fat
they called them bbws they don't call
them old I call them mature you know
it's like weirdly accepting you know
yeah you're not getting jizz on your
face you're getting a facial you know
yeah the way you did the terminology
yeah it is it is kind of like I don't
know it is you could say they don't like
themselves but then again you and I
don't like ourselves yeah as I said
there is a weird you do feel a weird
connection they seem to the ones I've
met have been very nice so Tara Patrick
yeah spent on another one like it's
astonishing how normal their and
actually some of them are completely
[ __ ] crazy like in any business I'll
take you to the comic store I'll show
you some crazy comics really yeah by the
way you we're not gonna make a porn
we're gonna fix it back Yeah right it's
gonna slip my throat all over your face
so it's gonna be like the end of a born
it'll be here in a blood facial ladies
gentlemen that was Sam Errol what is
your special called it's called I got
this it's available on my website Sam
real calm or on a stand-up calm and
moral if you go to my Instagram it's the
link is in the BIOS amarelle and I and I
and I got a badge about morale mor RIL
and I got a basketball podcast too
because I am obsessed called pod don't
lie with my up with my buddy Stavros so
it's a ton it's a ton of fun sounds like
a dynamic name oh it's gonna be about
something like basketball you know it's
cold well there's an expression that
Rasheed Wallace kind of started called
ball don't lie
okay where he kind of talked he
basically he led the league in technical
fouls every year for just talking [ __ ]
to the rest so basically he he got
called for a foul that he didn't think
was a foul and then the guy shot the
free-throw and missed it and he yelled
at the ref ball don't lie so I just
loved that I loved the next question hey
Brendan shots gonna be in Vancouver on
Friday what is that that's uh Friday
February Laughs festival huh okay good
go see go see my boy Brendan Schaub I'm
sorry he couldn't make it that was my
fault
because I basically you know I had not
been shooting so I did Vancouver on
Sunday that city's amazing it is really
incredible it's [ __ ] great and you're
an Omaha Brian I'm an Omaha these shows
are almost sold out that so I got Friday
and Saturday the 28th and 29th the
Saturday shows are already sold out I
think that there's one I think there's
something cuz I just saw my taking
counts we can get two tickets there's
still stuff left for here they are
ticket stuff for [ __ ] Friday and yeah
yeah so yeah there's still there's still
tickets for The Late Show Friday and the
I think Saturday sold out already and
there's some tickets for the first show
on Friday so get your tickets
sorry about selling out I'm just super
talented I'm not sold out so if you want
to come to the comedy cats when we're a
local March 5th through 7th or Gotham
the 19th through 21st please come to
Lilly's club oh and now I'm gonna be at
Cobbs this not coming Tuesday February
25th for the make-a-wish Foundation nice
so come and [ __ ] support I'm not
making any money but I'm doing it SF
rules man yeah it's you ever go to Swan
oyster Depot the seafood spot and SF no
dude it was Bourdain's
favorite place it's the best I'm still
Swan got a guy who runs it looks like SF
Colin Quinn really is like the nicest
guy it's I'm telling you is like the
best alright as ever
I'll go there it's incredible good eye
Swan oyster Depot I love it there yeah I
know where that [ __ ] place is it's
the best seen that place something about
a lot of people being around oysters
makes me kind of grosses me out it's so
good though I'm telling you that's our
rules
all right Sam Morril thanks for thanks
for having me just one talking you yeah
I love you what this is the fighter and
a kid we're out